what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday marvel
studios gave us a new look at doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
that has a lot of new footage in it
specifically one very interesting scene
where it looks like they have revealed
the ancient evil elder god c'thun
possibly now there are two of these
being spotted in this trailer if you
look at the full-scale version of the
trailer so we're gonna talk about who
this could be is it c'thun because
c'thun has a lot of connections to wanda
very specifically chaos magic and the
dark hold he created the darkhold which
is going to be a pretty big part of
multiverse madness so we're going to
break it all down and tell you
everything you need to know in this
video and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe you don't miss out on
any of the latest marvel news alright
now this new tv trailer spot actually
has quite a bit of new footage in it and
it's quite a big deal and is kind of
causing quite a bit of controversy
online right now about what is actually
happening in one very specific scene now
there are actually three scenes that i
want to break down in this video today
but let's talk about this main scene
that could have c'thun in it now i
posted some stuff on instagram and on
twitter about c'thun and i saw a lot of
people actually asking me who he is and
he's very very important and has a huge
connection to specifically wanda
maximoff and her chaos magic so let me
explain who he is so billions of years
ago right after the earth was formed the
demiurge which was the sentient life
force of earth created the elder gods
one of which was c'thun now at first
these gods were all good they ruled the
world together and it was peaceful for
the most part and they ruled it
peacefully for about a million years and
during this time c'thun spent a lot of
time studying the mystical forces and
the mystical arts of the universe and
eventually he became the earth's first
black magician so he became pretty
powerful but then the elder gods kind of
started to turn into demons they became
bad and started to go at war with each
other well one of the elder gods who had
not yet been corrupted into a demon
gaelia went to the demiurge and asked
for a way to stop all these other elder
gods because she feared for the life of
the universe and all the new life that
would eventually come well she entered
the center of the earth and then she
gave birth to a tomb also known as the
egyptian god amun ra the god of the sun
which i'm sure we might actually see pop
up in moon night so keep an eye on that
but amen raw slash tomb went on to be
known as the god eater because he went
around and started killing these evil
elder gods well c'thun managed to flee
and escape by creating another dimension
known as the flickering realms or
sometimes known as the other realm
however before he left on mundagor
mountain c'thun put all of his knowledge
about the mystical arts about black
magic about magic in general he put all
of that on parchment that was
indestructible and he created the
darkhold some of you may know this book
because it was the book that we saw in
one division this is the book that wanda
is studying in the cabin in the
post-credits scene for one division and
this book is probably causing a good
majority of the trouble in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
because as you'll go to find out it's
pretty corrupt and is probably
corrupting wanda which is something that
i think we see in a scene here i think
wanda is tricking wong but we'll get
right to that after the finish of the
story so kfun created the darkhold and
he made that a physical link between
earth and his new home should he ever
choose to return now a lot ends up
happening between this time and the time
where he runs into wanda maximoff aka
the scarlet witch the darkholds pages
get scattered then they get put back
together then c'thun gets banished a lot
happens but here's where wanda maximoff
comes in the high evolutionary would go
on to build his citadel on mount
wondergore now the high evolutionary was
warned that c'thun might actually return
and then he did however the high
evolutionary doing experiments on
animals evolving them into almost humans
calling them new men managed to drive
back c'thun however right before he left
the world he reached out and he touched
an infant who was being born and that
infant was wanda maximoff the high
evolutionary had taken wanda and petro
maximoff to do experiments on them and
then would later on go on to return them
to their actual maximoff parents but
c'thun touched wanda marking her as a
potential vessel for the future for him
to return in and he also granted her
some dark magic chaos magic and
eventually somebody known as mordred
under the influence of c'thun captured
the scarlet witch and performed a ritual
allowing c'thun to actually use her body
as a vessel on earth and he did and he
went up against the avengers but of
course he was eventually defeated but
you can see how big of a connection here
c'thun and the darkhold have to the
scarlet witch and the last time we saw
wanda she was studying the darkhold and
we've seen the darkhold in the trailers
for doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness so here's the question these two
beasts that we see in the trailer for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness are they c'thun yes i realize
there are two of them but hey it's a
multiverse movie there are variants
there could be two or this could simply
be some type of magic that c'thun is
performing to duplicate himself remember
he spent a million years studying
domestic arts he knows a lot now one
thing that is happening in the scene is
it actually looks like wang and the
scarlet witch are fighting with each
other not against each other and it
looks like they're also fighting with
these two monsters all seemingly being
on the same team however i do believe
this is some form of c'thun because it
looks just like he looks like in the
comics so either they're putting a
little twist on him or he somehow
managed to duplicate himself but
addressing all of these characters
fighting together i don't think that's
the case there are a few explanations
that we can think of as to what is
actually happening here one is that
c'thun could have actually managed to
multiply himself and wang and the
scarlet witch are indeed fighting them
but they turn around to see others
behind them and they're kind of
surrounded that could be one instance
two they could all be fighting a much
greater threat and that could be the
evil wanda it seems pretty clear at this
point that wanda or at least a variant
of her or a version of her is going to
be the main villain of this film and it
looks like she's going to threaten the
entire multiverse so maybe these
characters right here including a
variant of the scarlet witch could be
fighting her together but what i
actually think is probably happening
here is that the scarlet witch is
somewhat tricky wong we've literally
seen wang being tortured by the scarlet
witch in some of the trailers she's not
gonna be good and i'm guessing that
these monsters who i do think is c'thun
aren't gonna be good either i think she
has summoned them somehow or c'thun is
actually controlling wanda at this point
and that's why she's evil so i think
this scene right here could be where
wang actually gets captured i don't
think he's fighting the fight that he
thinks he is and i hope he doesn't die
but let me know what you think now like
i said there are two other scenes that i
want to talk about the first one is in
kind of the beginning where doctor
strange goes and finds wanda and says we
could use an avenger now i like this a
lot because obviously it's a reference
to the avengers but i actually really
think that this movie is going to end
with wanda sort of destroying the
universe that we know which could be a
really smart move by marvel because if
you're trying to keep things fresh and
kind of make it different than the first
10 years of the mcu what better way to
do that than to kind of rewrite the
universe a little bit but it's funny
because wanda says there are other
avengers and doctor strange says will
get you back on a lunch box which shows
you that in this universe on earth the
avengers are indeed superheroes and
people love them and they do sell
merchandising which kind of makes you
wonder who gets the money for that
because sam wilson in the falcon and the
winter soldier was broke so i'm
wondering who gets the money for that
but the next scene is a blink and you'll
miss it scene of wanda she is in her
full scarlet witch uniform and if you
take a look at the background it looks
like she's probably at the carmitage and
as sad as it sounds i think this is most
likely her attacking the carmitage we've
seen the carmitage get attacked in
several of the trailers and tv spots by
now we've seen all the sorcerers prepare
for battle and like i said we've seen
wang kind of in shackles but the
shackles are made up of wanda's chaos
magic so wanda is coming and is going to
be pretty bad in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness but what is behind
this is she being possessed by c'thun is
the darkhold corrupting her let me know
your thoughts on this in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]
me